[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants bon soit pas trop
d'accord mon gros nounours tu leur
montre le livre et moi je leur raconte
la suite des aventures du petit
cornichons mon le jeu
[Musique]
au sam
bonsoir si cela ne bouge pas comme sow
voilà tu est posée et maintenant tu nous
montres la suite de l'histoire de
cornichons et du son cheval data avoue
patron vous pouvez raconter vous pas
trop aujourd'hui notre petite amie
corniche on ramasse de l'osier dans la
forêt ça se mange nounours mais tout
petit colin alors qu'est ce que c'est
c'est avec de l'osier de grande liane
souple que le papa de cornichons tresses
de beaux paniers notre petite amie en a
déjà une belle gerbe dans les bras et
ils s'assoient dans l'herbe pour faire
la causette avec un petit oiseau perché
sur une branche d'arbre
le petit oiseau chante et cornichons lui
répond en sifflant cornichons cornichons
je veux que tu m'as tu rappes cet oiseau
je veux l'emmener dans ma maison et le
mettre dans une cage lui dit la grosse
dame rouge qui est arrivé voilà ce
qu'elle est méchante que lilo perçoit
pas mais cornichons siffler très fort
dans ses doigts pour dire au petit
oiseau de s'en aller bien vite et celui
ci s'envole très haut dans le ciel mais
c'est bien fait la crosse dame rouge
devient encore plus rouge de colère
cornichons cornichons tu vraiment intro
élèves son parapluie au dessus de la
tête du petit garçon heureusement dada
arrive à toute vitesse en faisant
beaucoup de bruit avec ses gros sabots
et cornichons saute sur son dos et il
laisse la dame rouge tout seul dans la
forêt ça lui apprendra seule la wii
tales of
il traverse les bois au grand galop et
ils arrivent à leur roulotte petits
cornichons donne à son papa losier qui
l'accueillît pour lui so bann est très
content car il va pouvoir faire de beaux
paniers et pour remercier son fils
il prend sa guitare il se met à jouer
tandis que la maman prépare la soupe du
soir
[Musique]
allons enfants
l'histoire est faite de belles vous a
plu ah oui elle est très jolie cette
histoire merci petit marchand de sable
blond le pitch ou d'autres où la suite
le bo ne m'a dit avant les noces
panis-nicolas boni pape rhône elle tend
bien bonne nuit petites tapes rhonelle
bonne nuit petit nicolas bonne nuit tous
les enfants allie sagement vous coucher
et faites de beaux rêves
fuck bord mots voleurs potro alors en
route mon cher nounours
bon et nuit à demain ottoman bonne note
[Musique]